dent meine damen und herren am 21 april
hat dieses haus abschließend über die
sogenannte bundes notbremse entschieden
das ist ein gesetz das eine ganze reihe
tiefer grundrechtseingriffe enthalten
hat und einigen hier im haus gingen
diese grundrechtseingriffe noch nicht
weit genug
der vorsitzende der cdu/csu-fraktion
ralph brinkhaus hat ausweislich des
stenografischen berichtsjahr hier zu
protokoll gegeben dass wenn er alleine
hätte entscheiden können
die eingriffe noch ich zitiere härte und
schärfe zitat ende geworden wären
wegen eines solchen politik
verständnisses das in der ohnehin
schweren zeit der krise nur eines kennt
nämlich immer härter und immer schärfer
in die freiheit der bürgerinnen und
bürger einzugreifen ist es ein großes
glück dass unsere verfassung die
grundrechte kennt denn die grundrechte
richten an die politik eine botschaft
und diese botschaft lautet nicht die
bürgerinnen und bürger schulden dem
staat eine begründung für ihre freiheit
sondern es ist der staat der den
bürgerinnen und bürgern eine begründung
für jeden einzelnen grundrechtseingriff
schuldet und das kann man dieser tage
gar nicht oft genug sagen
corona ist eine schwere gefahr
wir erinnern uns alle an die
schrecklichen bilder aus bergamo wir
sehen die schrecklichen bilder aus
indien jeden tag und daher ist es ja
klar dass es auch vernünftige regeln
gibt das ist auch eine ganze reihe von
grundrechts einschränkungen gibt die
natürlich vernünftig begründbar sind
aber dass man geimpften und genesene
nicht erlaubt einzukaufen ihre wohnung
zu verlassen ihre angehörigen zu sehen
einzukaufen sport zu treiben auch mit an
die impften und genesenen gehört nicht
dazu denn wir wissen mittlerweile dass
für diese personengruppen das gilt was
die mediziner sterile immunität nennen
nach menschlichem ermessen ist es eben
höchst unwahrscheinlich dass sich diese
person selber anstecken können oder dass
diese person andere menschen anstecken
können ihre freiheitseinschränkung ist
deshalb kein beitrag zur pandemie
bekämpfung wenn grundrechtseingriffe
aber keinen beitrag zur pandemie
bekämpfung leisten dann ist die pandemie
bekämpfung auch keine vernünftige
begründung für diese
grundrechtseingriffe das gilt bei
geimpften genesenen und auch das kann
man dieser tage nicht oft genug sagen
meine damen und herren
all das ist nicht neu
all das wussten wir schon als die bundes
notbremse beschlossen worden ist
wir haben es ihnen hier vorgetragen sie
haben das ignoriert wir haben dazu
änderungsanträge zum gesetz vorgelegt
sie haben diesen änderungsantrag
niedergestimmt
und plötzlich ganz schnell meint man die
schlimmsten fehler korrigieren zu müssen
bei dieser personengruppe man wundert
sich plötzlich wird auf das lka
abgestellt plötzlich erinnert man sich
an die begründungspflicht ich kite von
grundrechten in wahrheit war das alles
schon feuer bekannt es gibt nur eins was
sich geändert hat in der zwischenzeit
gibt es eine unzahl von
verfassungsbeschwerden auch die
verfassungsbeschwerden der 80
abgeordneten der fdp fraktion
und deshalb ist es gut dass es in diesem
haus nicht nur politiker gibt die meinen
immer härter und immer schärfer in die
freiheit eingreifen zu müssen sondern
die ihre aufgabe darin verstehen als
hüter und anwälte der grundrechte zu
agieren meine damen
daran hat sich übrigens auch nichts
durch die entscheidung des
bundesverfassungsgerichts gestern zu
gewissen eilanträgen geändert über
unsere verfassungsbeschwerden und unsere
eilanträge ist nicht entschieden worden
und über die rechte der geimpften sagt
diese entscheidung gar nichts außer
einem hinweis macht euch in die spur
groko sonst wird euch großes um gemacht
und ich kann die lektüre der
entscheidung nur empfehlen was das
gericht ausdrücklich nicht gemacht hat
ist eine rechtliche würdigung weder was
die behandlung von genesen und dürften
an geht noch was die ausgangssperren
angeht ich will ihn nur zitieren aus den
erwägungen des ersten senats der zweite
satz lautet schon bei der entscheidung
über den antrag auf einstweilige
anordnung haben die gründe achtung die
für die verfassungswidrigkeit der
angegriffenen maßnahmen vorgetragen
werden grundsätzlich außer betracht zu
bleiben das verfassungsgericht hat eben
nicht gesagt dass die massnahmen in
ordnung sind sondern hat eine rein
tatsächlich folgenabwägung vorgenommen
und auch das muss man dem einen oder
anderen sagen der meint das
verfassungsgericht habe sich auf die
seite der schneller und härter der
privilegien fraktion gestellt derjenigen
die bis heute nicht verstehen wollen
warum man den grundrechte nicht
eingreifen darf wenn es dafür keine
vernünftige begründung gibt meine damen
und herren kollegen in der aktuellen
stunde fünf minuten sind um
ja und die fdp-fraktion die hatte diese
aktuelle stunde schon beantragt bevor
die verordnung der bundesregierung auf
die tagesordnung gesetzt wurde und die
fdp hat aber gesagt für solch ein thema
sind 30 minuten debatten zeit zu wenig
deswegen ist sie dabei geblieben
diese aktuelle stunde hier im parlament
zu verlangen
karl marx spricht jetzt für die
unionsfraktion
das ziel die freiheit für geimpfte und
natürlich auch für die gemessenen so
schnell wie möglich wieder herzustellen
und gerade deshalb hat die regierung in
abstimmung mit uns und mit den ländern
die schutzmaßnahmen ausnahmeverordnung
vorgelegt schnell rechtlich einwandfrei
und genau deshalb war die koalition der
verordnung heute morgen auch zugestellt
beratung und abstimmung über das letzte
wochenende kabinett am dienstag
bundestag heute bundesrat morgen
verkündung am samstag in kraft treten am
sonntag ich meine mehr geschwindigkeit
mehr unmittelbarkeit geht nicht mehr und
sie liebe kolleginnen und kollegen von
der fdp hatten jedenfalls auch heute die
chance ihren einsatz für die freiheit
nicht nur anzukündigen
das passiert jedem relativ oft sondern
mit ihrer zustimmung zur
rechtsverordnung auch zu beweisen dass
es ihnen dann damit ernst ist kraftvoll
mithalten haben sie schadet sie haben
die chance vertragen und wie gesagt ich
teile das ziel was ich nicht teile ist
ihr arbeitseinsatz für das unangenehme
ich die harten maßnahmen um die
infektionszahlen runde zu bringen
da ist die koalition zuständig so viel
verantwortung wollten sie auf seiten der
fdp dann doch wieder nicht übernehmen
sie klinken sich ein quasi nach der
pflicht wenn es wieder um die kür geht
ihr leib und magenthema die
freiheitsrechte ja wie eine koalition
haben wie der sogenannten notbremse
dafür gesorgt dass bei einer inzidenz
von über 100 bundeseinheitliche
maßnahmen
das infektionsgeschehen eigene und herr
buschmann ich stehe hier als
gesundheitspolitiker ich teile den
ansatz meines fraktionsvorsitzenden ich
hätte es sogar noch wirklich mit
strengeren maßnahmen probiert aber
richtig ist auch die notbremse erst seit
23 april in kraft sorgt jetzt bereits
heute dafür dass die inzidenz in
deutschland endlich wieder sinkt ich
erinnere 23 geführt
187 bundesweit heute 129 und die
rückläufigen zahlen die ihm genau auf
diese notbremse zurück und das sage
nicht nur ich liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen kann
zitat wir sind zuversichtlich ich
zitiere den präsidenten der deutschen
interdisziplinären vereinigung für
intensiv und notfallmedizin professor
max wir sind zuversichtlich dass die
zahl der komik 19 patienten auf den
intensivstationen sinken wird und das
fängt unmittelbar mit den massnahmen der
bundesrat bis mit den deutlichen
fortschritt zusammen und liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen uns geht's
natürlich vor allem um die menschen
ich freue mich jetzt falle das mit der
ausnahmeverordnung zum beispiel für
geimpfte und genese der genesene
senioren in den einrichtungen wie der
geselligkeit möglich ist besucher
kartenspielen schlicht lebensqualität
und sie haben vorher das stichwort
spaltung der gesellschaft in den mund
genommen
ja wir haben auch den jüngeren
generation in dieser pandemie sehr viel
zugemutet erst mussten sie sich zum
schutz der alten menschen auf ihr
normales leben mussten sie verzichten
dann muss
sie schimpfen hinten sich einreihen
aber auch da und das sage ich jetzt sehr
bewusst ist licht am ende des tunnels in
mainz ist im wesentlichen die
prioritäten gruppe 3 dran sind die
verkäuferin das sind die busfahrer all
jene die nicht im home-office sein
können und die auch schon seit vier
monaten auf die impfung warten und
anfang juni ist es dann soweit wenn die
priorisierung aufgehoben wird dann sind
auch die jungen gesunden waren und die
herzliche bitte an geringeren vier
wochen es geht um vier wochen
ich bitte herzlich noch einmal um so
viel geduld und mehr freiheit über fdp
geht es auch für die kinder und
jugendlichen
bisher ist der impfstoff von bayerns mit
jahres ab 16 zugelassen kanada ist der
impfstoff jetzt bereits zwischen für die
jugendlichen zwischen 12 und 15 wenig
zugelassen gleiches für europa beantragt
im juli aller voraussicht nach werden
wir den impfstoff für die kinder und
jugendlichen ab zwölf haben alles in
allem die lage ist ermutigend
impfkampagne läuft 30
erst geimpfte 9 prozent vollständig
geimpften gestern 200.000 zwei impfungen
insgesamt gestern 1,1 millionen
impfungen pro tag das hat bisher noch
kein einziges europäisches land
geschafft die betriebsärzte ab siebten
juni sind sie dabei
das impfen wird für alle noch mal bequem
im laufe des juni aufhebung der
priorisierung an den weiteren parameter
zeigen
die richtige richtung über 10.000
teststationen sichern den rechtsanspruch
auf mindestens einen kostenlosen
schnellprozess pro woche öffnen test
gestützt eine reale perspektive und wir
bleiben bei unserer maxime vorsicht und
umsicht wollen wir beibehalten und zu
für sich kann es heute an alle
zuhörerinnen und zuhörern vermitteln
herzlich karl marx war dass die
gesundheitspolitische sprecherin der
unionsfraktion hier mit einem
zuversichtlichen beitrag auf sie folgt
jetzt der tüv spangenberg er ist für die
fw fraktion der obmann im
gesundheitsausschuss
[Applaus]
herr präsident jährige damen und herren
fdp freie demokratische partei
sie fordern freiheit für geimpfte das
heißt die vorderen einschränkungen für
alle anderen was ist daran frei und was
ist daran demokratiefragen ich kann das
nicht erkennen
meine damen und herren sie wollen auch
wenn sie sohn sein und rennen die
regierungsparteien andrea wir sagen
grundrechte sie nicht verhandelbar und
dürfen nur um äußerst nicht aber unter
unsicheren gesichtspunkten gezogen oder
je nach gutdünken menschen wieder
zuerkannt werden oder deutlicher sind
grundrechte nun privilegien oder normal
falls die frage eine opposition wie wir
es verstehen hat eine bedeutet
demokratische parlamentarische aufgabe
auch sich einer selbstherrlichen
regierung entgegen zu stellen
genau dies machen sie nicht im gegenteil
sie treibt mit ihrem antrag eine
anbietens politik die sich gewaschen hat
wer auch die fdp die grundrechts
einschränkungen gefährdung des
rechtsstaates mit fördern mit befördern
mit durchsetzen
wir sehen es so wenn betont wird es
handelt sich um grundrechts
einschränkung ist dies nicht ausreichend
definiert
denn es sind hier wesentliche
grundrechte nämlich die freiheitsrechte
also mich noch verhältnismäßig noch zu
akzeptieren ist professor lepsius
professor für öffentliches recht und
casas theorie westfälisch während
universität in münster bezeichnete schon
vor einem jahr
die reaktion von regierung und
gesetzgeber als einen so sagt er
ziemlich flächendeckenden ausfall
rechtsstaatlicher argumentation
standards dem rechtlich wie ethisch
geboten umgang mit den grundrechten wird
die momentane rechtfertigungsrede jedoch
nicht gerecht grundrechte können die
unter beachtung der verhältnismäßigkeit
eingeschränkt werden und damen und
herren können wir ab kommender woche
unser grundrechte durch impfung oder
durch eine genesungs bescheinigung
zurück erlangen oder für einen tag
grundrechte für eine befristete zeit
härtesten es sieht so aus
ist das die perspektive in einem
demokratischen recht
die afg sagt nein es ist nicht damen und
herren
nun haben wir genau das was es angehen
ich nie geben sollte eingehen um seine
freiheitsrechte wenigstens teilweise
wieder erlangen zu können
viele maßnahmen auf diese die
einschränkung der bürgerrechte
wir grünen sind wissenschaftlich
umstritten nicht haltbar
erstens die tests abend schnelltest
selbst setzen mit so großen fehlerquoten
behaftet dass man sie nicht verwerten
kann wenn überhaupt dann gibt es nur
einen sinn bei menschen die symptome
vorzeigen
das ist die anhörung von 16 14 21
ausschuss für gesundheit von maxi waren
dabei incidence werde willkürlich
festgelegte zahlen die wir ihnen absatz
3 des § 28 b der intelligenz wertung 165
für einen präsent unterricht
ausgehandelt mit einer kugel bei der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
die ermittlung von den sie denn es
werden mittels leistungen daraus
ermittelt neuinfektionen sanader dich
nicht immer die anzahl von erkrankten
schwere von krankheitsverläufen
behandlung von patienten oder auslastung
von ines investitions intensivstation
aus professor krüger vorgänger von
doktor trotz der charité bande andere
parameter an die berücksichtigung der
von brennpunkten krankheitshäufigkeit
schwere erkrankung und so weiter die
masken pflicht auch hier
unterschiedliche unterschiedliche
gravierende meinungen nach viele
mediziner kritisieren das ist
gesundheitlich bedenklich ist wenn man
viele stunden am tag die eigene atemluft
wieder einatmen muss kopfschmerzen
übelkeit sind die folgen
und wo soll der nutzen sei meine damen
und herren werden diese beiden
geschlossenen räumen verlangt club in
dem sie schon eine einzige person erhält
nämlich zum beispiel an die bundesbahn
wenn sie allein im abteil sitzen
impfstoffe ständig hin und her bei der
anwendung empfehlung und einschränkungen
zum beispiel asthmatiker
herstellung zulassungsbehörden sagen
keine einschränkungen
die stimmung sagt nur über 60 jahre und
die zweite dosis am besten eine andere
impfstoff entschieden werden auch noch
dokumentiert und personen unter 60
jahren in einigen ländern wasserstoff
ich zugelassen und jetzt mal eine frage
meine damen und herren haben die
menschen nicht das recht darüber zu
sprechen darüber besorgt zu sein
sie sind deshalb gleich eine gefahr für
die demokratie wenn sie eine impfung
nicht wollen oder ähnlich vertrauen das
ist die frage
ausgangssperren aber so medizin noch
verneinen die anstrengungen außenbereich
fast gänzlich was sollte an eine
ausgangssperre
was soll ein verbot für ein gartenlokal
ist die regierung so arrogant meine
damen und herren dass sie jeden der noch
22 uhr auf die straße geht als
potenziellen kneipengänger deklarierte
an den nächsten spielen gefolgt waren
besser als tauscht ist auch so gemacht
meine damen und herren es sieht
schlimmer sie an deutschland
sie wird nun überprüft werden und gerade
seine grundrechte genießen darf und sich
daher zum zeiten der ausgangssperre 1000
aufhalten darf er sich gerade in seinem
zuhause mit mehreren und anderer mensch
drückt soll dann private zusammenkünfte
in wohnungen gestürmt werden und damit
es im pass festzustellen dass sich die
mündliche treffen dürfen werden dann von
der polizei oder ordnungsamt haben so
nachts personenkontrollen durchgeführt
alle zur selbstverständlich die ard
steht für zielgenaue schutzmaßnahmen für
besonders gefährdet für die freie
entscheidung für oder gegen eine impfung
für vater und rechtsstaat meine damen
und herren sie könnten für das land und
vielen kollegen der klub spangenberg war
das für die afg fraktion und auf ihm
sitzt wiese er ist mitglied der
sozialdemokraten dort bundestag in einer
aktuellen stunde mit dem titel
freiheiten für geimpfte und gemüse
umgehend wieder herstellen
[Musik]
sehr geehrter herr präsident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen als zum
jahresbeginn 2021 bundesjustizministerin
christine lambrecht eine debatte
angestoßen hat das wenn es erwiesen ist
wenn es wissenschaftlich erwiesen ist
diejenigen die vollständig geimpft sind
die chinesen sind nicht mehr das virus
weiter verbreiten nicht mehr infektiös
sind dass man hier letztendlich andere
rechtliche maßstäbe anlegen muss weil
verhältnismäßigkeit bei einschränkungen
nicht mehr gewahrt ist da hat sie viel
viel kritik einstecken müssen auch von
vielen kolleginnen und kollegen hier aus
diesem haus auch gerade aus der
opposition aber es war richtig
frühzeitig auf diese debatte aufmerksam
zu machen und wir haben jetzt als
bundesregierung mit den
koalitionsfraktionen in der vergangenen
woche in der woche schnell gehandelt
nachdem das rk ii festgelegt
festgestellt hatte wissenschaftlich
untersucht hat dass diejenigen die
letztendlich die doppelte impfung haben
die immunisiert sind das die
letztendlich nicht mehr in der form
infektiös sind und darum war es richtig
auch heute schnell und zügig zu handeln
und diese verbunden bundesverordnung
übrigens mit zustimmung des deutschen
bundestages und die zustimmung des
bundesrates steht noch auf den weg zu
bringen das war ein richtiger schritt
und gebietet auch rechts staatliches
handeln
und ich glaube meine damen und herren
wenn wir auch und die erfreulichen
zahlen der der letzten tage anschauen
dass wir fast 30,6 prozent 30,6 prozent
erstimpfungen haben der fast wir fast
gestern 1,1 millionen impfungen haben
dann zeigt es doch wirklich dass es
voran gehen dass es viel viel licht für
die kommenden wochen gibt dass es eine
klare perspektive gibt dass es vorangeht
dass auch die von olaf scholz mit
initiierte task force
impfstoffproduktion ein wichtiger
schritt gewesen ist auch hier
letztendlich mehr wieder möglich zu
machen und von daher gebietet dass viele
möglichkeiten die ausdrücklich in die
richtige richtung gehen ich bin
allerdings
herr buschmann ein bisschen erstaunt
einmal freue ich mich dass sie diese
aktuelle stunde angemeldet haben sie
haben sich wahrscheinlich gewünscht dass
sie zu einem früheren zeitpunkt gewesen
ist jedenfalls habe ich manchmal bei
ihrer rede gemerkt dass die eigentlich
schon nicht mehr da tagesaktuell gewesen
ist jedenfalls nach einigen was wir
heute beschlossen haben aber ich glaube
und das muss man auch sagen wir sind
nach wie vor in einer nicht einfachen
situation und wenn man sich die
folgenabwägung des beschlusses
bundesverfassungsgerichts von gestern
abend anschaut dann hat das
bundesverfassungsgericht in einer eil
entscheidung das hauptsacheverfahren
kommt noch ja gesagt dass es noch immer
hohe incidents zahlen bei uns gibt dass
es immer noch gefährliche virus
varianten gibt dass wir immer noch
schwere krankheitsverläufe und eine hohe
zahl an todesfällen haben dass wir immer
noch letztendlich die wirksamkeit
bereits erfolgter impfungen in frage
stellen würden wenn wir zu viel und auch
zu schnell auf einmal lockern würden und
ich muss das auch ganz klar bei ihnen
sagen das was sie hier mit dieser
aktuellen stunde suggerieren dass sie
mehr öffnungen jetzt schon haben wollen
dass sie mehr freiräume jetzt schon
haben wollen dadurch gefährden sie die
fortschritte die gerade in den letzten
zwei drei vier wochen passiert sind und
ich kann wird es den wagen den blick
richten wir sie es auf angesprochen
schauen sie nach viele schauen sie nach
indien das waren länder die große
fortschritte erzielt haben die viel
vorangebracht haben die dann allerdings
zu früh unachtsam gewesen sind die zu
früh gelockert haben die zu früh auch
veranstaltung wieder zugelassen haben
ich kann nur sagen wir wollen diesen
erfolg den wir momentan sehen diese
positiven signale die wir sie nicht
durch zu frühe komplett lockerungen wie
sie sich das vorstellen gefährden dann
würden wir es eher dazu führen dass wir
dann möglich
weise wieder verschärfung mitmachen
wollen was keiner von uns haben möchte
und darum halte ich das was sie damit
vorangebracht haben in teilen auch
verantwortungslos und ich muss auch
deutlich sagen was die bürgerinnen und
bürger neben einer klaren perspektive
wollen übrigens die hotels bei mir im
sauerland fordern eine perspektive für
den ersten siebten was sie auch wollen
ist verlässlichkeit und planbarkeit und
da muss man auch mal den blick in einige
landesregierungen richten und wenn ich
den blick zur landesregierung nach
nordrhein-westfalen richte zu haben die
in nastätten und ihrem
wirtschaftsminister pinkwart dann will
ich ihn mal ein paar beispiele dafür
geben wie man bürgerinnen und bürger
verunsichert es gibt ihn mal das erste
beispiel schule die schulpolitik die
ihre schulministerin gebauer in
nordrhein westfalen nach ist
ehrlicherweise protest und sorgt für
verunsicherung bei schülerinnen und
schülern bei lehrern das was sie da
gemacht haben hat so viel verunsicherung
beigetragen und hat zu recht wird auch
ausgelöst bei eltern lehrern und bei
schülerinnen und schülern da kann man
nur sagen sitzen sechs versetzung
gefährdet für die leistung die sie
abgeliefert haben ich gebe ihnen noch
zwei beispiele in der bundes notbremse
haben wir festgelegt dass es ausnahmen
geben soll für buch leben nordrhein
westfalen hat das nicht mit aufgenommen
die buchläden in nordrhein-westfalen
mussten vier tage lang nicht was sie
machen sollten was sie tun sollten ihr
wirtschaftsminister keine anpassung in
der korona schutzverordnung vorgenommen
hat nicht gehandelt buchläden
unternehmer verunsichert das ist politik
bei ihnen in nordrhein westfalen und der
letzte punkt ich halte es für richtig
über modellregionen nachzudenken ich
glaube das kann bei sinkendem incidents
wird eine möglichkeit sei bei mir im
hochsauerland sind kommunen
modellregionen geworden sie warten noch
heute darauf dass es klare kriterien des
nrw wirtschaftsminister sting feiert
gibt auch da in der praxis sie
verunsichern die bürgerinnen und bürgern
sie machen das gegenteil in
regierungsverantwortung was sie hier
erzählt das ist unverantwortlich und das
ist keine politik mit perspektive die
die fdp in den ländern
der krise der stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende der fdp fraktion
war das und wir haben eben schon im bild
gregor gysi gesehen
der ist hier für die linksfraktion der
nächste redner in dieser aktuellen
stunde präsident liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen grundrechte sind weder
privilegien noch sonderrechte sondern
stehen jeder bürgerin und jeden bürger
in unserem land zu deshalb können sie
auch nicht zurückgegeben werden wie
habeck meint denn sie gehören uns nicht
sie stehen im grundgesetz dazu hören
zügigkeit die vollständigen
versammlungsfreiheit das recht auf kunst
und kultur auf bildung und ausbildung
und vieles andere
wenn es durch den bundestag tatsächlich
einschränkungen von grundrechten
grundgesetz gemäss geben soll
da muss es dafür schlüssige zutreffende
und verhältnismäßige gründe im interesse
der allgemeinheit geben zum beispiel im
gesundheits interesse um es juristisch
einmal ganz klar zu sagen wenn wir 1000
personen nehmen und von 999 geht eine
gefahr aus die zur einschränkung ihrer
grundrechte zwingt aber von dem 1000
nicht hat niemand das recht diese mine
tausendsten seine grundrechte zu
entziehen so weit sie bei verbot für die
anderen überhaupt noch gewährleistet
werden können deshalb wird es höchste
zeit dass die vollständig geimpften die
genesenen und die negativ getesteten
ihre grundrechte so weit wie möglich
wieder wahrnehmen können ich kenne
natürlich die hinweise aus der
wissenschaft dass es notation der viren
geben kann
das ist möglich solange es aber keine
reale gefahr für hunderttausende oder
millionen menschen gibt darf eine solche
überlegung hinsicht durch eine
möglichkeit niemals zur einschränkung
von grundrechten führen damit verletzte
mann das prinzip der verhältnismäßigkeit
ich weiß das ist auch vollständig
fünfte genesene und negativ getestet
eine sehr sehr seltene ausnahme der
gestalt haben können dass die einen die
viren trotzdem übertragen können oder
die anderen doch positiv waren
wenn zum beispiel von diesen 1000
gegebenen für einen diese ausnahme
zutreffen sollte hat niemand das recht
auch den übrigen 999 bürgerinnen und
bürger die grundrechte weitgehend zu
entziehen oder einzuschränken wiederum
verletzte mann das prinzip der
verhältnismässigkeit wenn man
vollständig geimpften gelesen und
negativ getesteten die grundrechte
weitgehend einräumte steht eine soziale
frage so weit test zum beispiel in
unternehmen von den beschäftigten
bezahlt werden müssen ist dies
abzuschaffen die tests müssen regelmäßig
für alle nicht geimpften und nicht
genesen vom staat gebührenfrei zur
verfügung gestellt werden hier gibt es
neben der sozialen frage noch eine
weitere überlegung die bundesregierung
und die eu-kommission tragen die volle
verantwortung dafür dass die kapazitäten
hinsichtlich der impfstoffe so gering
waren das bisher nur prozent unserer
bevölkerung vollständig geimpft sind
das ist ein einzigartiger skandal wenn
also die regierung den jüngeren noch
kein impfstoff anbieten kann muss sie
ihn gebührenfrei
die tests zur verfügung stellen damit
sie so umfassend wie möglich ihre
grundrechte wahrnehmen können übrigens
habe ich hier unterschiede im denken
zwischen ost und west fest festgestellt
im westen denkt man nur an bestellung
und bezahlung im osten weiß man dass man
auch überkapazitäten nachdenken muss
insofern wundert es mich dass die frau
bundeskanzlerin merkel da auch nicht
gekommen ist aber sehr schön
außerdem schützen sie ständig die
freiräume und nicht die innenräume
die ansteckungsgefahr ist innen aber
viel größer als draußen ich erwarte von
ihnen endlich eine pflicht für die
unternehmen für home office so weit es
geht eine testpflicht dort in bestimmten
abständen und investitionen auch des
staates für luftfilter und luft rein
in großraumbüros und klasse zu meinen
erstaunliches auch das chaos der
regierung
am letzten freitag haben sich noch gegen
grundrechte für vollständig geimpften
genesene und negativ getesteten geräte
nun haben sie eine verordnung
beschlossen die doch teilweise die
wahrnehmung der grundrechte ermöglicht
ich vermute sie haben angst vor dem
erfolg der verfassungsbeschwerden gegen
das bevölkerungsschutz gesetz beim
bundesverfassungsgericht
wenn alle vollständig geimpften genesen
und negativ getesteten ihre grundrechte
wieder weitgehender wahrnehmen dürfen
wären nur noch positiv getestete und
jene die sich nicht testen lassen wollen
obwohl sie noch nicht geimpften und
genesen sind von wesentlichen
einschränkungen der grundrechte
betroffen bei den positiv getesteten
hoffen wir auf baldige genesung und für
die wahrnehmung der grundrechte durch
alle bürgerinnen und bürger muss eine
herdenimmunität erreicht werden die
spätestens bei einer impfquote von 70
prozent der bevölkerung eintritt heute
abend wird namentlich unser antrag zur
aufhebung des patentschutzes für diese
impfstoffe bundestag abgestimmt er dient
der finanzierung gerade für die armen
länger us-präsident hat offensichtlich
unseren antrag gelesen fand ihn gut und
deshalb zumindest die befristete
aussetzung des patentschutzes gefordert
ich bin gespannt wie die anderen
fraktionen heute abend darüber abstimmen
werden stehen sie an der seite der armen
auch der usa und der linken oder nicht
das wird spannend vierte bundesregierung
gewährte bundesregierung lägen sie was
das impfen betrifft nun endlich den
turbo ein
beenden sie das chaos und sorgen sie
dafür dass so schnell wie möglich
sämtliche grundrechte in deutschland für
alle wieder eingestellt
sie wollen dass die linken und die
grünen haben mit den
koalitionsfraktionen hierfür die
rechtsverordnung heute vortrag auch
bestimmt dass es erleichterungen für
vollständig gegen das corona virus
kämpfte und von der erkrankung genesene
geben soll
hier ist in kambodscha spricht als
nächstes die sprecherin für
gesundheitsförderung von bündnis 90/die
grünen kolleginnen und kollegen vor
wenigen tagen traf ich eine gute
bekannte in bremen und sie hatte gerade
ihre zweite impfung erhalten
es fallen wir so viele steine vom herzen
sagte sie sie war dankbar erleichtert
dass sie selbst jetzt wie im
wesentlichen geschützt ist und auch
andere nur noch also im wesentlichen
nicht mehr anstecken kann und dass sie
ihre ebenfalls zweifach geimpfte
nachbarin jetzt wieder besuchen kann
und das haben wir heute morgen hier
beschlossen dass kontakt beschränkung
für doppelt geimpfte jetzt im
wesentlichen wegfallen und das ist gut
denn darum denn darum geht es doch dass
einerseits der infektionsschutz groß
geschrieben wird und selbstverständliche
grundrechte wieder
selbstverständlich werden auch im
pflegeheim beispielsweise wo die
bewohnerinnen und pflegekräfte geimpft
sind wird jetzt gemeinsames essen
gemeinsames leben wieder möglich und so
schützt die impfung nicht nur vor einer
infektion sondern eben auch vor
einsamkeit grundrechte heißen eben
grundrechte weil sie grundlegend sind
sie grundieren die freiheit und würde
jeder person in unserem land und wenn
sie nicht mehr für den infektionsschutz
notwendig sind die einschränkung dann
müssen sie eben aufgehoben werden aber
herr kollege buschmann was sie hier
erzählt haben das hat mich doch wirklich
sehr verwundert denn es geht hier doch
nicht um härte beim infektionsschutz
es geht doch um konsequenz und den
schutz für unser aller
doch noch ist sind wir mitten in der
dritten welle die intensivstation sind
noch voll
auch menschen mit einem leichten kurve
19 verlauf haben in den ersten sechs
monaten nach einer erkrankung ein
höheres risiko zu versterben jede zehnte
person leidet an longo wird es sind erst
acht prozent der bevölkerung sowie meine
nachbarin vollständig geimpft und wenn
wir jetzt zu schnell lockern so wie sie
das fordern hat das virus die besten
bedingungen eine neue resistente
mutation zu entwickeln
dafür dürfen wir doch nicht die augen
verschließen eine vierte welle mit einem
noch gefährlicheren virus müssen wir
doch auf jeden fall verhindern
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen und ich
habe wirklich große sorge dass wir wegen
der freude die wir alle teilen über das
licht am ende des tunnels die debatte zu
früh auf öffnungen fokussieren in
anderen ländern wurde aufgrund des
wahlkampfs in steigende zahlen in
steigende zahlen der infektion hinein
der infektionsschutz gelockert und das
hat schlechte folgen niedrige inzidenz
werte sind die grundlage für
verantwortungsvolle öffnungen damit dann
die sportplätze theater die
außengastronomie so schnell wie möglich
wieder sicher geöffnet werden können
damit für kinder und jugendliche spaß
und spiel wieder mehr raum bekommt
solange kinder und jugendliche noch
nicht geimpft werden können und junge
menschen noch kein impfangebot haben
tragen sie ein besonders hohes risiko
wenn die schutzmaßnahmen jetzt
nachlassen und wenn jetzt die impfungen
für kinder und jugendliche hoffentlich
bald zugelassen werden dann ist das ein
meilenstein und schon dafür
jetzt die impfkampagne vorbereitet
werden müssten die kinder mehr in den
blick nehmen es ist entscheidend dass
jetzt alle schnell ein angebot erhalten
das ist leicht zugänglich wird durch die
betriebsärztin am arbeitsplatz durch
mobile im teams gezielt da wo viele
menschen zusammen geben und auch global
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen und darum
sollte sich deutschland und die eu jetzt
den usa anschließen und die patente für
den chor und corona im stoff aussetzen
und wer noch nicht geimpft werden konnte
muss durch einen negativen schnelltest
gleiche zugänge zu gastronomie oder
kultur wenn sie dann schritt für schritt
verantwortungsvoll wieder öffnen können
bekommen genauso wie geimpfte und
genesene gerade eltern junger familien
oder studierende und auszubildende
dürfen wir nicht vergessen
unser ziel muss also sein die
kolleginnen und kollegen so viel
freiheit für so viele menschen so
schnell wie möglich die verschiedenen
bevölkerungsgruppen aber die dürfen wir
doch nicht gegeneinander ausspielen
unser höchstes gut ist die akzeptanz der
bevölkerung und ein vernünftiger
stufenplan der würde akzeptanz und
perspektive bringen also konsequenter
infektionsschutz weiterhin solange er
notwendig ist und begegnungen
endlich wieder da wo sie durch
schnelltests genesung oder impfung
wieder sicherer
möglich sind vielen dank kirsten katar
konter von den grünen hat hier longo
wieder angesprochen und tatsächlich wird
sich das parlament auch mit den
spätfolgen der chor ohne erkrankung
beschäftigen die fdp und die
linksfraktion haben hier eine
antrag eingereicht und das ist denn
nächste tages über nächste
tagesordnungspunkt jetzt aber erstmal
carsten müller für die unionsfraktion
ich glaube ich werde ihre erwartungen
nicht vollkommen erfüllen weil aus ihrer
sicht werde ich einiges falsch sagen
aber sie die tragik ist in folgende das
ganze ist ein folgenden gegründet ich
glaube gar nicht dass sie es richtig
absichtlich vor hatten aber sie haben
sich in ihrem verhalten in den
diskussionsbeiträgen denn heute vor
laufenden abstimmungen auch in den
positionierungen ihrer partei aus meiner
sicht ich bin damit nicht alleine in
eine ungute nähe zu ihren nachbarinnen
und nachbarn aus meiner sicht weiter
rechts gegeben und das macht eben ihre
situation im moment sohn vom portal
meine damen und herren
wie war der ablauf es war in dieser
woche absehbar dass wir dass wir die
verordnung zur regelung von der leistung
und ausnahmen von schutzmaßnahmen zur
verhinderung der verbreitung von cobit
19 diskutieren und verabschieden werden
und sie kamen mit ihrer aktuellen stunde
die dasselbe thema nämlich die
freiheiten für geimpfte und genesene
nicht wieder zurückzugeben sondern genau
darüber zu debattieren das zu
veranlassen
sie kam mit ihrer aktuellen stunde
bedauerlicherweise etwas zu spät wie sie
in dieser diskussion ohnehin häufig
etwas spät kam und auch etwas wenig
präzise gearbeitet haben sie haben es
anders gemacht
wir haben uns der verantwortung gestellt
und konstruktiv gehandelt bereits mit
dem vierten herr kollege teurer
sie haben ehrlich gesagt sich verweigert
aber dazu kommen wir gleich noch bereits
mit dem vierten gesetz zum schutz der
bevölkerung
bei einer epidemischen lage von
nationaler tragweite haben wir die
bundesregierung in den stand gesetzt
durch eine rechtsverordnung die der
zustimmung des bundestags ist bedarf
erleichterung und ausnahmen von geboten
und verboten für immunisiert oder
negativ getestete vorzulegen es war im
übrigen die fdp die diese nicht
zugestimmt hat sie haben insofern sich
dieser dieser diskussion vollkommen
entzogen und es ist ja
bedauerlicherweise auch nicht das erste
mal dass sie sich der verantwortung
entzogen haben in den letzten vier
jahren meine damen und herren in einem
zügigen und zielorientierten
parlamentarischen verfahren hat die
koalition dieser verordnung in dieser
woche zugestimmt
um mit der zu erwartenden bestätigung
des bundesrates werden wir die
einschränkung für geimpfte und genesene
wahrscheinlich ab sonntag denn effektiv
abgeschafft haben derzeit band ist von
vorrednerin und vorrednern schon
dargestellt wurden wir haben diese
verordnung heute mittag angenommen und
meine damen und herren das war auch
dringend angezeigt und geraten und das
ist eben tatsächlich gelebte
verhältnismäßigkeit und
verantwortungsvolles handeln denn
grundrechts beschränkungen und einen
schönen kunden stets nur ultima ratio
also letztes mittel sein
daher ist es zwingt die beschränkung
genauso entschlossen und im übrigen
genauso verantwortungsvoll
zurückzunehmen wie solche beschränkungen
zum schutz der bevölkerung der personen
vor schäden an gesundheit und leben
ergriffen worden sind positive
entwicklung der korona infektionszahlen
setzen uns jetzt in der stand dieses
machen zu können und meine damen und
herren
da teile ich nicht die auffassung des
kollegen gysi wir haben das nämlich
tatsächlich mit einem impfstoff jetzt zu
tun
es gab versäumnisse in den ersten drei
monaten aber die beschleunigung war so
stark dass der impfstoff wahrscheinlich
an ihnen vorbeigefahren ist das ist das
ist bedauerlich aber so ist die realität
kein anderes land in europa liegt im
moment ein derartiges tempo vor um meine
vorredner hat richtigerweise auch mit
persönlichen erlebnissen untermauert das
sind die gespräche wie auch an mich
herangetragen werden
darum geht es und das ist gut und das
bringt eben auch entspannung in die
diskussion gestern waren 25 einhalb
millionen menschen das erste mal geimpft
7,2 millionen menschen waren sind
vollständig geimpft die zahlen zum
heutigen nachmittag sind schon deutlich
höher
wir erwarten heute wieder mehr als eine
million impfungen wir werden bei den
zweikämpfen wahrscheinlich knapp bei
siebeneinhalb millionen liegen das alles
ist besonders erfreulich und meine damen
und herren das führt dazu dass
beschränkung die absolut schwierig zu
entscheiden waren aber ergriffen werden
mussten das diesel für immer weniger
menschen gelten werden das ist ein
großer schritt zurück in die normalität
ich freue mich darüber und das ist eben
auch das helle licht am ende des tunnels
für die geimpften und genießen und es
eine perspektive für die wirtschaft für
die gesellschaft für kultur kunst die
selbstständigen wir haben es diskutiert
die probleme der selbstständigen die
probleme von leuten die in russland erst
frisch zugewandert sind aber auch
natürlich junge familien familien mit
kindern kinder und jugendliche erst
erstklässer die das große erlebnis
schule gar nicht haben mitbekommen
können und das sind solche fälle über
die wir auch im nachgang reden müssen
deswegen ist dieses neustadt paket
unbedingt wichtig ich warne vor einem
nämlich vor einer zu großen
leichtsinnigkeit ist auch
verschiedentlich angesprochen worden
kollege wie satz gesagt meine vor
richterin hat gesagt wir schauen nach
chile und sehen dass dort nach einer
besonders erfreulichen entwicklung
ein riesengroßes desaster eingetreten
ist
das zahlt die gesamte gesellschaft und
die sozial schwächeren zahlen die
höchsten preis und das wollen wir nicht
und deswegen handeln wir
verantwortungsvoll vielen dank
carsten müller war dass er hat sich hier
auch an die kollegen gewandt in seiner
rede auf ihn folgt jetzt martin reichert
er sitzt für die fdp fraktion im
ausschuss für familie senioren frauen
und jugend einige davon sind ja in
dieser pandemie besonders getroffen von
einsamkeit zum beispiel sehr geehrter
herr präsident sehr geehrte damen und
herren wir reden heute über sogenannte
freiheiten für genesene und geimpfte die
fdp nennt es freiheiten die regierung
formuliert es handelt sich insofern
nicht um die einräumung von
sonderrechten oder privilegien sondern
um die aufhebung nicht mehr
gerechtfertigter grundrechtseingriffe
man kann das alles noch so gestelzt
daher formulieren im klartext heißt das
im pflicht durch die hintertür eintritt
in die zwei klassen gesellschaft
diskriminierung gesunder menschen und
das werden wir von der ard niemals
mitmachen
im gegensatz zu allen anderen hier im
hause vertretenen fraktionen stehen wir
zu unserer verfassung wir stehen zum
grundgesetz zur demokratie zur freiheit
und eigenverantwortung jeder bürger in
deutschland hat das recht und die
freiheit selbst zu entscheiden ob er
sich auch in der korona frage impfen
testen lassen will oder eine maske trägt
diese entscheidung darf für den menschen
keine nachteile keine repressalien und
keine ächtung innerhalb der gesellschaft
nach sich ziehen meine damen und herren
[Applaus]
aber genau das genau das wird auch durch
ihre zwischenrufe hier vorangetrieben
nicht geimpfte gelten angeblich als
unsolidarisch sie sind sogar wie man
hört schädlich für die gesellschaft und
das sind äußerungen die wir in
deutschland nie wieder hören wollen
meine damen und herren die asd fordert
schon seit langem
gebt den menschen ihre freiheit und ihre
grundrechte zurück denn 99,8 prozent der
menschen haben kein koma der anteil der
korona infizierten in der bevölkerung
liegt bei 0,22 prozent und infiziert
heißt nicht einmal krank und für alle
fakten checker und alle ausgelagerten
zensur stellen der regierung diese
zahlen kommen vom statistischen
bundesamt
es besteht also keine notwendigkeit
diese rede zu sperren
grundrechte sind keine privilegien die
der staat willkürlich aufheben kann
grundrechte sind kein privileg die
grundrechte sind jedem einzelnen eigen
und sie werden nicht vom einzelnen durch
wohlverhalten durch die abgabe eines
tests oder eine impfung erst erworben
und das sollten sie sich alle hier
mitnehmen meine damen und herren
grundrechte sind unveräußerlich so steht
es im grundgesetz
seit aber in deutschland in der korona
frage anders als bei allen krankheiten
die es sonst noch so gibt wie grippe
krebs und herzinfarkt der totale
gesundheits staat ausgerufen worden ist
gerät unsere verfassung zusehends unter
druck und das ist schlimm
die regierung will geimpften mehr
freiheiten mehr
rechte einräumen sie treibt damit die
spaltung der gesellschaft weiter voran
die sogenannten volksvertreter aller
parteien außerhalb meiner fraktion sind
in diesem hause leider zum abnickverein
der kanzlerin geworden meine damen und
herren beim abnick verein der sich
nebenbei gerade hier aus dem mittleren
bereich noch die taschen vollstopft ein
abnickverein der nicht mehr das volk
vertritt dass unter den
unverhältnismäßigen maßnahmen leidet
sondern einseitig einer panik doktrin
boston und lauterbacher provenienz folgt
mit ausnahme der anti grundrechtspartei
von den grünen die die bundes notbremse
sogar schon ab einer inzidenz von 35
oder 50 forderte und damit noch
totalitärer ist als die regierung das
leben der menschen in deutschland wird
also mit den grünen noch düsterer wenn
diese verbots ideologen der einst die
macht in deutschland übernommen haben
meine damen und herren es ist aber auch
heute schon sehr düster für millionen
gesunder kinder die ihr recht auf
bildung mit einem zwangs test und bald
vielleicht auch mit einer zwangsimpfung
erkämpfen müssen das lehnen wir in aller
deutlichkeit und aller entschiedenheit
ab meine damen und herren
und wir müssen uns die frage stellen ob
es in deutschland noch gewaltenteilung
gibt wenn richter die unliebsame urteile
gefällt haben mit hausdurchsuchungen
drangsaliert werden wenn künstler mit
berufsverbot bedroht werden weil sie
eine abweichende meinung haben da hätte
ein aufschrei durch dieses haus hier
gehen müssen
ich komme zum schluss sie alle tragen
die verantwortung dafür dass unsere
demokratie alt
bleibt und menschenrechte nicht davon
abhängig werden ob man eine bestimmte
gesinnung oder einen bestimmten
impfstatus hat vielen dank soweit martin
reichert und gewählte von den bürgern
und bürgerinnen gewählte volksvertreter
und keine sogenannten sondern gewählte
nur zu platz hier nochmal eine
klarstellen wir haben hier eben den
fraktionsvorsitzenden der fdp alexander
gauland gelesenes gesehen
hier sehen wir wieder dass er gerade das
neue buch von sahra wagenknecht die
selbstgerechten anscheinend auch durch
liest also durchaus einen blick nach
links sagt heike behrens spricht jetzt
als nächstes sie ist vorsitzende des
unterausschusses globale gesundheit der
sich unter anderen mit
infektionskrankheiten oder ebola
beschäftigten und kollegen
wir werden uns alle grundrechte und
freiheiten wieder zurückerobern
das habe ich bürgerinnen und bürgern
gesagt und geschrieben die sich besorgt
zu den grundrechtseingriffen geäußert
haben
ich konnte tatsächlich nicht ahnen wie
lange es dauert aber jetzt ist es soweit
und wir halten wort jetzt wo
wissenschaft uns bestätigt dass von
geimpften und genesenen nur ein geringes
risiko ausgeht das virus zu verbreiten
jetzt wo mehr und mehr leute immer
schneller die impf werten können erste
beschränkungen zurückgenommen werden
das haben wir dem virus in großer
gemeinsam
anstrengungen abgerungen wie wichtig und
wertvoll das ist das hat unsere
ministerin christine lambrecht heute
morgen schon thematisiert wie wichtig
und wertvoll das ist zeigt sich gerade
in pflegeeinrichtungen und einrichtungen
der behindertenhilfe
nur wenige wurden so extrem
eingeschränkte in ihrer lebensqualität
wie menschen die in
gemeinschaftseinrichtungen leben ihr
bewegungsspielraum wurde auf ein kleines
zimmer reduziert indem sie lange nicht
einmal besuch bekommen konnten
freiheits räume die die meisten von uns
in der familie und draußen immer wieder
immer noch hatten waren für sie äußerst
reduziert und deshalb ist es ein grund
zur freude dass wir diese lebensqualität
gerade für diejenigen in einer
wohnsituation die auch ohne pandemie von
einschränkungen geprägt ist jetzt zurück
gewinnen
ich habe das beispiel der
seniorenresidenz mühlehof in lörrach vor
augen
bis auf eine bewohnerinnen wurden alle
bewohnerinnen und bewohner geimpft und
über 90 prozent der mitarbeitenden
ebenso und dennoch durften sie über
monate nicht gemeinsam sich zum
mittagessen treffen erst nach langem
malen der mühlen von verwaltung und
justiz wurde eingelenkt und jetzt
endlich können seniorinnen und senioren
sich and wie endlich wieder zum essen
treffen oder auch für andere
gemeinschaftsveranstaltungen auch
jenseits von verordnungen und gesetzen
müssen infektionsschutz maßnahmen mit
augenmaß und ich finde auch mit
beherztem pragmatismus abgewogen werden
gerade dann
wenn es um die allerletzte phase im
leben geht und ich denke wir sollten
einrichtungen diensten und
pflegepersonal zu trauern hier
individuelle und verantwortungsvolle
entscheidungen zu treffen sind freiheit
und verantwortung müssen immer in
balance gehalten werden
viele hatten vielleicht weniger angst
vor eigener erkrankung aber trafen
freunde trotzdem nur digital junge
menschen sagten geburtstage und
abschluss feiern ab nicht aus angst um
die eigene gesundheit sondern weil sie
nicht zum infektionsgeschehen beitragen
wollten weil sie vernünftiger waren als
die vertreter sind von der rechten seite
sondern weil sie jeden andere schützen
wollten weil sie menschen mit
vorerkrankungen und ältere schützen
helfen wollten und ich verstehe gut dass
es für junge menschen kaum noch
auszuhalten ist das wichtige
meilensteine des erwachsenwerdens
aufgeschoben oder gar verpasst werden
und umso bemerkenswerter finde ich dass
gerade sie eine enorme solidarität über
generationen hinweg gezeigt haben ich
finde das fordert unser aller respekt
ich habe auch großes verständnis dass
nun gefragt wird wann sind wir endlich
dran dann können wir wieder sport
treiben normal zur schule gehen
verreisen denn auch für familien besteht
weiterhin die enorme belastung schule
oben office eingeschränkte freiheit
freizeit zu organisieren
ja wir brauchen einen plan für öffnungen
wie es olaf scholz ein fahrer und da
müssen kinder und familien im
mittelpunkt stehen
wir haben uns alle mit einem kraftakt
gegen das virus gestimmt und das jetzt
erst das jetzt erste lockerungen dass
jetzt die ersten lockerungen nicht
sofort für alle gelten das ist trotzdem
notwendig bleibt aber schwer für ganz
viele und deshalb muss weiter alles
tann daten um allen die es wollen
schnell ein impfangebot zu machen und
darum dort bald mit dem fortschritt auch
das weiteren impfstoffe die
impfstrategie entsprechend angepasst
werden weitere ärzte wie die
betriebsärzte mit einbezogen und vor
allem auch impfstoffe für kinder und
jugendliche entwickelt das alles macht
hoffnung und lässt uns noch etwas
geduldig sein denn jede weitere impfung
ist ein schritt hin zur öffnung für alle
vielen dank heike behrens war das für
die spd fraktion und auch wenn es jetzt
lockerungen geben soll solche bereiche
wie die gastronomie die muss ja
weiterhin warten ob denn die instanz
fälle nach unten gehen die fdp fraktion
fordert weiterreichen öffnungen für sie
spricht jetzt michael theurer sie denn
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen sehr
verehrte damen und herren der vorwurf
der kollegen karl marx und carsten
müller die diskussion heute nachmittag
sei gegenstandslos und nicht notwendig
wegen der verordnung der bundesregierung
geht völlig ins leere denn erstens nimmt
ja die verordnung der bundesregierung
die einschränkungen für geimpfte und
genießen nur punktuell zurück zb sind
weiter teile die öffnung von geschäften
von hotellerie gastronomie und
veranstaltungen komplett ausgenommen
und zum zweiten ist der entscheidende
punkt der das wenn von immunisierten
personen keine infektionsrisiken
ausgehen dann lassen sich grundsätzlich
keine einschränkungen ihrer freiheit
mehr rechtfertigen dies wurde hier
eindrucksvoll auch von gregor gysi
bestätigt ich kann an der stelle
feststellen dass wir mehr gemeinsam
haben als nur unsere frisur kollege dies
ist auch der einsatz für unsere
grundrechte
meine damen und herren auch die
argumentation von karin markt die bundes
notbremse hätte zum rückgang der
insolvenzen geführt entspricht ja
offensichtlich nicht den tatsachen denn
wenn sie sich mal ich hab mal hier die
john hopkins universität mitgebracht
die infektionszahlen anschauen rot zeigt
die schweiz blaue zeigt die
bundesrepublik deutschland dann gehen ja
in der schweiz die zahlen wesentlich
deutlicher zurück als in der
bundesrepublik das heißt die bundes
notbremse deutschlands wirkt in der
schweiz offensichtlich besser als in der
bundesrepublik und das obwohl meine
damen und herren die schweiz bereits
anfang märz lesen museen außen sport und
zoos geöffnet hat die schweiz hat mitte
april die außengastronomie starter und
fitness studien geöffnet meine damen und
herren also ohne helme meine damen und
herren ihre argumentation die bundes
notbremse den rückgang der inzidenz hier
eingeleitet kann den tatsachen nicht
entsprechen sondern im gegenteil es muss
andere gründe haben wahrscheinlich der
fortschritt des im verlauf es aber auch
die frische luft denn weniger
ansteckungen in der frische frischen
luft das wird ja auch von den aero so
forsch und klar gesagt führen dazu dass
wir raus sollen nichts der traum sondern
raus an die frische luft bewegung dort
im freien das minimiert die
ansteckungsgefahren und meine damen und
herren deshalb auch eine ganz klare
aussage wenn das rk ii recht hat dass
die meisten infektionen im privaten
bereich stattfinden dann muss die
antwort doch sein wer private saufgelage
verhindern will dann muss die
außengastronomie wieder öffne meine
damen und herren david mit hygiene
konzepten hier entsprechen die menschen
sich auch wieder treffen können
entscheidend ist aber dass von geimpften
offensichtlich keine ansteckungsgefahren
in erheblichem umfang ausgehen das zeigt
auch die oxford studie darauf beruhen ja
auch jetzt die empfehlungen das eben
alle freiheitseinschränkung für geimpfte
und genesene zurückgenommen wird da
stellt sich dann aber schon die frage
warum eigentlich die bundesregierung die
warnungen man müsse die impfstoff
produktionskapazitäten erhöhen nicht
angst genommen hat und herr kollege gysi
es gab auch kapazitäten im westen
jedenfalls habe ich die bundesregierung
mündlich bereits im mai und schriftlich
im juni darauf hingewiesen dass
impfstoff kapazitäten erhöht
warten müssen das ist aber nicht mit
entsprechendem nachdruck verfolgt werden
und herr kollege sparen wenn sie sich
jetzt in etlichen auch tweets und social
media auftritte freuen über den
fortschritt und da bin ich bei ihnen
dann hätten sie an der stelle vielleicht
einmal für die bundesregierung der
entschuldigung aussprechen können
da dafür dass eben anders als in den usa
die impf bestellung in deutschland in
der europäischen union nicht mit dem
notwendigen nachdruck nicht rechtzeitig
genug nicht mit den entsprechenden
mengen und auch nicht mit den gleichen
preisen gefordert worden ist wie zb
israel oder in den vereinigten staaten
von amerika und meine damen und herren
der dritte punkt sind die modellprojekte
ich schaue mir damals das land schleswig
holstein
da machen die fdp landesminister bahn
buchholz und heiner garg die arbeit und
der ministerpräsident günther rühmt sich
heute in der bild zeitung für die
erfolge der modellprojekte wir sind für
modellprojekte und frau kollegin mark
wir haben änderungsantrag zu ihrem
gesetz gestellt um diese modellprojekte
auch in zukunft zu ermöglichen den haben
sie genauso wie der kollege carsten
müller
in namentlicher abstimmung abgelehnt und
das ist ja auch die begründung warum wir
ihrem gesetzentwurf nicht zustimmen
konnten
es hätte die verordnung für die
geimpften heute gar nicht bedurft wenn
sie unseren änderungsantrag zugestimmt
hätten
der eben für geimpfte und für genesene
entsprechende ausnahmen vorgesehen hat
auf uns hören heißt rechtzeitig auf
nachbesserungen verzichten zu können und
deshalb bleiben wir dabei das was sie
bitter verordnung gemacht haben ist ein
schritt in die richtige richtung reicht
aber nicht aus wenn von geimpften und
genießen keine infektionsrisiken mehr
ausgehen dürfen für diese menschen
freiheitsrechte nicht länger
eingeschränkt werden wir werden nicht
müde dies an dieser stelle einzufahren
[Applaus]
nächste redner ist der kollege lothar
riebsamen cdu csu fraktion war präsident
verehrte kolleginnen und kollegen die
freien demokraten haben zweifelsohne
einen besonderen bezug zum thema
freiheit im allgemeinen und in die
wieder individuelle freiheitsrechte im
besonderen dass wir überhaupt nicht an
aber ich bin mir sicher hat euer recht
wenn wir ganz sicher dass umgekehrt dass
umgekehrt die fdp auch den parteien die
das heft nicht schon im parteinamen
tragen sondern im programm haben nicht
absprechen dass sie jetzt nach einem
jahr pandemie und nach einem jahr
einschränkungen durchaus von
freiheitsrechten das ist so die gleiche
sehnsucht haben wie die fdp auch
möglichst schnell wieder zurück zu
kommen zur normalität und möglichst
viele freiheitsrechte auch wieder
einzuräumen die bisher nicht eingeräumt
werden konnte und aus gutem aus gutem
grund in den vergangenen tagen muss man
allerdings auch sagen ist die skepsis
auch bei manchen menschen gestiegen
das wollten wir wahrscheinlich an
unseren e mails auch bei mir war es
jedenfalls so dass viele e mails in den
vergangenen tagen auch mich erreicht
haben die da die auffassung vertreten es
komme alles jetzt zu früh
es ging ihm zu schnell es sei
unsolidarisch gegenüber denjenigen die
noch keine bach gott dieses ding
es sei unsolidarisch gegenüber denen die
noch keine impfung erreicht haben
ich bin allerdings der auffassung dass
es nicht nach dem motto gehen kann
geteilt
das leid ist halbes leid ich denke es
ist richtig das gegenteil zu sagen sich
zu freuen mit denen die eine impfung
schon erreicht haben die wieder ihre
freiheitsrechte zurück bekommen wir
haben heute morgen vor zwei stunden
die entsprechenden beschlüsse für die
geimpften gefasst und darüber sollten
wir uns freuen und ich bin sicher dass
die notbremse herr teuer wie wir sie
eingeführt haben für die inzidenz werte
über 100 in deutschland sehr wohl genau
zu diesem punkt geführt haben mit den
impfungen natürlich zusammen dass wir
freiheitsrechte wieder einräumen können
und ich freue mich für die schweizer
wenn sie mit ihren maßnahmen
vergleichbares erreicht haben aber ohne
die notbremse und das können sie anderen
ansatz zeitachse ganz genau fest während
die inzidenz zahlen nicht so gefallen
wie sie in den vergangenen tagen fallen
es wäre der erwerb nicht so
zurückgegangen es wäre die belegung der
intensivstation nicht so zurückgegangen
das lässt sich doch einfach so einfach
belegen und sollte jetzt nicht also
thema der diskussion überhaupt seien es
liegt auf der hand es ist es ist
geradezu evident und erinnern möchte ich
in diesem zusammenhang an eine
empfehlung des deutschen ethikrats vom
februar 2021 mit der überschrift
besondere regeln für geimpfte wenn ich
das zitieren darf da steht je mehr aber
mit den fortschritten des impfprogramms
besondere gravierende risiken reduziert
worden und verbesserte kenntnisse
hinsichtlich der
ansteckungsfähigkeit vorliegen desto
eher sind individuelle rücknahmen von
freiheits einschränkungen für geimpfte
personen vorstellbar und gegebenenfalls
auch geboten und diese empfehlung des
deutschen ethikrats ist plausibel klug
und richtig und aus diesen und auch aus
diesem grund haben wir vor zwei stunden
die entsprechenden beschlüsse gefasst
und den geimpften und vergleichbaren
personengruppen ihre freiheitsrechte
wieder zurückgegeben und ich bin
zuversichtlich aufgrund der sinkenden
instanzen einerseits und der massiv
ansteigenden zahlen der der geimpften
andererseits dass wir zügig in diese
richtung in den nächsten wochen auch
fortfahren können das wünsche ich uns
allen aber nicht bevor ich sage und
abschließend darauf hinweise dass
natürlich die schutzpflichten nach wie
vor bleiben es muss weiterhin getestet
werden es müssen weiterhin die hygiene
vorgaben eingehalten worden
die abstände eingehalten worden und wir
haben jetzt 71 millionen menschen
geimpft und noch nicht alle und auch das
ist ein grund dafür dass wir weiterhin
die bullen gruppen schützen müssen die
eindämmung der maßnahmen müssen insofern
ein stück weit noch für einige wochen
aus gutem grund gründen in kraft bleiben
aber wir sind auf einem guten weg
herzlichen dank lothar riebsamen war das
für die unionsfraktion hier in der
rückrunde die die fdp fraktion beantragt
hatte und dennis trainer ist sebastian
hartmann er ist mitglied im
parlamentarischen begleitung gremium zur
pid 19 pandemie dass der
gesundheitsausschuss gegründet hat
sehr geehrte damen und herren wir
blicken auf 14 monate einer
unvergleichlichen herausforderung die
unser land in die welt gefordert hat wie
keine der herausforderung den letzten
jahrzehnten
das ist der eine teil der andere teil
ist wenn man sich an den positiven
dingen orientieren will wir reden über
viele millionen von menschen die jeden
tag impfungen erhalten und haben eine
debatte also sogar verschiedenste
impfstoffe gibt die man dazu führen dass
wir weiter teile der bevölkerung
immunisieren können und darum geht es
hier in dieser debatte und der fdp die
eine aktuelle stunde angesetzt hat und
es ist vielleicht auch etwas aus der
zeit gefallen wenige stunden nachdem wir
ja schon als große koalition gehandelt
haben und entsprechende rücknahmen
beschlossen haben bei den
grundrechtseingriffen sollten uns an
eine stelle noch mal erinnern
wir haben begonnen damit dass wir keine
behandlungsmethoden bekannten wir
mussten mit diesem neuartigen virus
umgehen lernen es gab keine situation in
der wir aus impfstoffen wehren konnten
und zu sagen das ist die impfung für die
und die gruppe in die wir hinein gehen
wollen und sie zu schützen meine damen
und herren das ist etwas was wir als
parlament getan haben und der fdp
blendet anteil dieser debatte aus denn
der grundrechtseingriff ist doch nur
deswegen vorgenommen worden um auf zeit
auch zeit zu gewinnen denn wir hatten
keine behandlungsmethoden wir waren
nicht in der lage bestimmte gruppen zu
schützen
ja wir haben eine bundes notbremse
beschlossen um einheitliche regelung zu
haben denn akzeptanz und transparenz
sind wichtig dass man klar was daran
orientieren wir uns wenn wir bestimmte
maßnahmen aber sie von der fdp sie
nehmen sich nur ein teil dieser
diskussion und sie sind zu spät weil die
entsprechenden beschlüsse heute schon
gefasst worden sind denn diese
grundrechtseingriffe dürfen nur so lange
stattfinden wie sie auch gerechtfertigt
sind und gerade dann wenn menschen
vollständig genesen sind und vollständig
geimpften entfällt der wesentliche grund
für diesen grundrechtseingriff und
dieser verantwortung sind weite teile
dieses hauses demokratisch nachgekommen
liebe kollegen
und ein zweiter teil der debatte in die
fdp immer wieder ausblenden kann ich
ihnen nicht ersparen denn eng verbunden
mit der idee der freiheit ist ja auch
die des handlungsfähigen staates der
überhaupt die grundvoraussetzung schafft
wenige monate vor der debatte um die
pandemie gab es doch noch diskussionen
gerade aus ihren reihen krankenhaus
kapazitäten im ländlichen raum zu
reduzieren das gesundheitswesen im markt
diktat zu unterwerfen sie waren es doch
die genick die einsparungen vorgenommen
haben die tarifbeschäftigten eben nicht
in der pflege wollen die alles den markt
überlassen worden und sie haben auch in
ihrer regierungsverantwortung dazu
geführt dass dieser staat an den rand
der leistungsfähigkeit kam und keine
vorsorge keine massen gekauft worden
sind keine ressourcen entsprechen
bereitgestellt
also können sie sich diesen teil der
debatte auch nicht ersparen wenn sie
sich wenn sie waren von 2009 bis 2013
verantwortlich und sie waren stolz
darauf teile des personals einzusparen
wenn sie heute an die kommunen die nicht
in der lage sind den öffentlichen
gesundheitsdienst ausreichend zu
finanzieren sind sie hauptverantwortlich
dafür
und sie können sich nicht in einen teil
dieser debatte heraus dem und über
freiheit gehen wenn sie es auf der
anderen seite wenn sie schreien geben
sie mir doch recht wenn sie auf der
anderen seite nicht der der lage sind
den bürgern und bürger klar zu denen das
ist ein starker leistungsträger staat
auch eine grundvoraussetzung für die
freiheit aller menschen in diesem land
ist meine damen und herren
da ist das problem
sie nehmen sich immer nur ein teil der
debatte weil sie die gesamte wahrheit
nicht ertragen sie haben uns an den rand
der handlungsfähigkeit gemacht mit ihren
spar logischen und deswegen können wir
stolz darauf sein dass wir in der
pandemie 14 monate danach uns nicht nur
ein teil der verantwortung und normal
sondern die gesamte verantwortung für
dieses land übernommen gesagt haben wir
wollen bessere löhne in der pflege wir
wollen krankenhäuser besser finanziert
wir wollen impfstoffen für die breite
masse zu organisieren und wir wollen
dafür sorgen dass diese pandemie eine
veränderung bringen und zwar zum
positiven und wenn das ein lerneffekt
ist dann war es gut dass die fdp diese
aktuelle stunde beantragt hat und
endlich diesen punkt auch mit nimmt als
städte und zu belehren liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen müssen damit leben dass sie
den gesamten teil der debatte haben und
sie können sich nicht nur den teil der
lockerung nehmen wenn sie auf der
anderen seite nicht die entsprechenden
einschränkungen mittragen wolle oder die
finanzierung dieses gemeinwesen das ist
ihr problem und das ist ein teil der
debatte die sie bewusst ausblendet und
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen die
debatte gehört es ist wahr die debatte
gehört hier ins parlament und gerade in
diesem moment tag das begleit gremium
des deutschen bundestages in dem vierten
ausschuss und führt eine anhörung zu den
rechten geimpfter durch zu erfragen der
empörung und ich finde es wichtig dass
diese debatte hier im parlament
stattfindet und nicht in nicht
öffentlichen debatten der
ministerpräsident ministerpräsident die
bürgerinnen und bürger in diesem land
teilnahme anspruch zu wissen wo stehen
die parteien und wo wollen sie hin und
das liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ist
der gute teil dieser aktuellen stunde
die ansonsten weiten teil völlig
überflüssig war
lieber fdp-mann endet hier mit
zweideutigen fazit dass er seinerseits
ist es gut hier darüber zu sprechen
andererseits hat die aktuelle stunde
überflüssig alexander gauland folgt der
debatte zum teil zum teil schande hier
in das buch von sahra wagenknecht
vertieft zu sein der ehemaligen
fraktionsvorsitzenden der linksfraktion
alexander hoffmann ist der letzte redner
für die unionsfraktion
gestatten sie mir zunächst eine
vorbemerkung wir führen eine sensible
debatte
und natürlich ist es so dass die
verwirklichung von freiheits garantien
des grundgesetzes die wir hier im
mittelpunkt haben für uns treibende
kraft ist
aber wir müssen in der debatte und schon
auch mal die zeit nehmen der blick auf
diejenigen zu werfen die noch nicht
geimpft sind weil sie noch keinen termin
bekommen haben
diejenigen die noch nicht geimpft sind
weil sie sich nicht impfen lassen können
ja und auch den blick auf diejenigen
richten die sich aus irgendwelchen
gründen nicht impfen lassen wollen ich
bekomme das wird ihnen genauso gehen aus
meinem wahlkreis viele zuschriften von
menschen die mir schreiben helfmann ich
bin kein corona lügner ich bin kein
impfgegner ich will mich auch irgendwann
impfen lassen aber mir macht die debatte
sorge weil ich habe angst vor einer
zweiklassengesellschaft und ich möchte
noch zeit weil ich will mich von meinem
hausarzt impfen lassen und ich möchte am
schluss auch entscheiden welchen im
stoff ich bekomme und die wahrheit es
hat auch meine damen meine herren das
eine gesellschaft eine krise nur dann
gut übersteht wenn sie geschlossen
bleiben und ich will ihnen von der fdp
sagen so wie sie die debatte befeuert
so ziehen sie gräben und sie schließen
sie nicht und ich habe ihm das jüngst
auch schon einmal gesagt das sie ihren
kurs überdenken sollten
ich glaube schon dass auch sie als fdp
der versuchung widerstehen müssen immer
wieder nach instrumenten zu greifen die
mehr spalten als zusammenbringen ich
will ihnen ein beispiel nennen
vor zwei wochen als wir die bundes
notbremse beschlossen haben hat sich die
fdp und auch andere im übrigen big buck
ich hingestellt und hat das ist
offensichtlich verfassungswidrig
jetzt haben wir die woche sie haben die
woche die quittung bekommen das
bundesverfassungsgericht hat sogar
ausdrücklich gesagt dass eine
ausgangssperre grundsätzlich ein
legitimes mittel ist kollege buschmann
da war von offensichtlich
verfassungswidrig nicht mehr geredet
aber ich will auch noch ein paar sätze
zur afg sagen
die fdp erreicht eine für mich völlig
neue ebene und ich vermeide bewusst das
wort niveau sie sagen das ist ein
mittelbarer impfzwang jetzt überrascht
mich das nicht ich sag mal das ist das
prinzip afd die afg schaut die ganze
debatte an und guckt was hat maximales
verletzungs potenzial was hat maximales
empörungspotenzial und wenn wir nichts
finden dann kommst du ihren wir halt was
aber viel spannender ist doch meine
damen meine herren von der afg eine ganz
andere frage wie sehen sie eigentlich
ihr freiheits versprechen für die
menschen in diesem land in einer zeit wo
klar ist dass die pandemie zunächst mit
lockdown maßnahmen bekämpft werden muss
bis wir zu ihm kommen was sagen sie denn
den menschen sagen sie den menschen denn
wenn sie gewinnt bitte geben sie nicht
vor die tür wenn sie eine fb2 maske
tragen bitte gehen sie nicht vor die tür
und auch wenn sie ein negatives
testergebnis haben gehen sie nicht vor
die tür weil sie sonst ja auf diejenigen
einen mittelbaren zwang ausüben würden
die all das nicht wollen ist das ihr
freiheitsverständnis der beweis den sie
damit erbringen liegt doch auf der hand
sie haben überhaupt kein interesse dass
wir gut durch diese pandemie kommen es
gilt der satz der afd
wenn es dem land schlecht geht geht es
der afg gut
der eigentliche hammer und deswegen habe
ich vorhin von neuer ebene gesprochen
der eigentliche hammer kommt am schluss
ich weiß nicht ob es ihnen aufgefallen
ist
im rechtsausschuss zumindest spricht die
afd
von einer minderheit wenn sie über die
menschen spricht die einen schweren
corona verlauf erlebt haben wenn sie
über die menschen sprich die
folgeschäden haben und die an corona
gestorben sind sie spricht von einer
minderheit in ansehung der todeszahlen
ohnehin schon ein unmöglicher witz aber
meine damen meine herren wir alle wissen
wir alle wissen wie despektierlich die
afd
über minderheiten denkt und wie die
spectral ich sie diesen begriff
einsätzen in bezug auf homosexuelle in
bezug auf menschen mit
migrationshintergrund und in bezug auf
menschen mit muslimischen glauben und
dass sie den menschen die einen schweren
corona verlauf hinter sich haben dass
sie die ihrem ihre minderheiten begriff
unterwerfen das lässt tief blicken
vielen dank für die aufmerksamkeit die
aktuelle stunde ist beendet